antes de adentrarnos en la notación
abreviada vamos a repasar la estructura
de las celdas galvánicas o voltaicas así
que recordemos que una celda voltaica
utiliza una reacción redox espontánea
para crear una corriente eléctrica así
que nosotros ya sabemos qué es lo que
ocurre en este electrodo de la izquierda
verdad digamos el electrodo de zinc
verdad o el zinc sólido digamos se
convierte en iones de 5-2 positivos así
que pensemos lo que ocurre con un átomo
de zinc que se está convirtiendo en
iones de zinc dos positivos verdad el
átomo va a tener que perder los
electrones estos dos electrones se van a
tener que perder y de ahí que podemos
escribir una semi reacción verdad así
que tenemos esencialmente
solido verdad que se está convirtiendo
vamos a hacerlo un poco más grande se
está convirtiendo en guiones de 52
positivos y termina en solución acuosa +
2 electrones verdad aquí estamos viendo
que en efecto se están perdiendo los
electrones así que esta pérdida de 2
electrones los ponemos del lado de los
productos y esta es una semi reacción de
oxidación verdad cuando perdemos
electrones obtenemos oxidación verdad
eso es algo que hay que recordar ahora
bien esos dos electrones que hemos
perdido esos estos dos electrones
digamos que tenemos aquí ahora van a
viajar a lo largo de todo este cable que
tenemos en esta celda verdad van a
viajar en esta dirección
nuestros dos electrones van a viajar y
esencialmente eso es lo que nos provoca
nuestra corriente eléctrica cierto
tenemos una corriente eléctrica en
nuestro cable y esos dos electrones se
están moviendo al
de la derecha verdad se están moviendo
al electrodo de la derecha estos son dos
electrones se mueven al electrodo de la
derecha que es cobre
ok tenemos este electrodo de cobre ahora
tenemos esos dos electrones en nuestro
electrodo de cobre verdad y en las
soluciones o más bien esta solución
digamos que tenemos en azul esta es una
solución de sulfato de cobre aquí lo
tenemos verdad sulfato de cobre así que
tenemos guiones de cobre dos positivos
tenemos iones de cobre dos positivos que
están en contacto con esos electrones
verdad y entonces obtenemos una semi
reacción de reducción así que vamos
vamos a escribirlo acá tenemos los iones
de cobre dos positivos en solución
acuosa que están en contacto con estos
dos electrones de hecho los van a
adquirir para convertirse en cobre
sólido muy bien obtenemos cobre sólido
así que en este caso la carga total es
cero y por lo tanto tenemos
sólido y nuevamente ahora aquí en este
caso hemos ganado electrones así que
esta es una semi reacción de reducción
vamos a escribir esto esto es una semi
reacción de reducción verdad y eso es
porque hemos ganado electrones así que
esto representa la semi reacción de
reducción y recordemos entonces que la
pérdida de electrones es oxidación y la
ganancia de electrones es reducción
verdad esta es una forma digamos
nemotécnica en la que podemos recordar
cuando algo es una oxidación y cuando
algo es una reducción ahora bien si
nosotros digamos sumamos estas dos
reacciones obtendremos la reacción redox
total verdad así que nosotros sabemos
que estos dos electrones que se pierden
del zinc son exactamente los dos
electrones que ganan en los iones de
cobre 2 positivo así que digamos los
podemos simplemente cancelar y ahora
veamos qué es lo que tenemos del lado
del oro
del lado de los reactivos tenemos
justamente zinc en digamos sólido más
guiones de cobre 2 positivo en esta
digamos en solución acuosa que nos
produce guiones de zinc 2 positivos en
solución acuosa más cobre sólido digamos
esto que obtuvimos aquí lo obtuvimos
simplemente del lado de los productos
cierto así que en resumen nosotros
teníamos zinc sólido verdad que se
convierte en iones de 52 positivo pierde
dos electrones esos dos electrones
viajan en el cable y llegan hasta el
otro electrodo que es de cobre verdad
luego los adquiere digamos esos dos
electrones los adquieren los iones de
cobre dos positivos ahora a medida que
pase el tiempo pensemos qué es lo que
ocurre cuando perdemos
verdad qué es lo que ocurre cuando
perdemos zinc bueno en este caso vamos a
perder zinc a lo largo del tiempo y por
lo tanto vamos a ganar cobre cierto
vamos a ganar cobre que es más o menos
este es el color digamos de este
electrodo y este cobre se va a depositar
en la superficie del electrodo verdad
entonces digamos que aquí se va a estar
acumulando el cobre y en esencia es es
digamos nuestra reacción redox
espontánea verdad que está creando
nuestra corriente eléctrica debido al
flujo de electrones en el cable ahora
regresemos a nuestras semi reacciones y
pensemos qué es lo que ocurre en los
electrodos nosotros sabemos que la
oxidación verdad la oxidación ocurre en
el ánodo verdad así que este electrodo
de aquí tiene que ser el ánodo muy bien
ese es el ano
de forma similar nosotros sabemos que la
reducción tiene que ocurrir en el cátodo
así que estoy acá es el cátodo
justamente este de aquí es el cátodo y
este será el ánodo ahora vayamos
rápidamente a ver qué es lo que ocurre
con el puente de sal que tenemos justo
en medio verdad y vamos a utilizar el
color rojo verdad nosotros tenemos
sulfatos verdad tenemos uniones de
sulfato en nuestro puente de sal aquí
los tenemos y los aniones migran hacia
el ánodo así que esto es algo muy fácil
de acordarse verdad los aviones migran
hacia el ánodo así esto es muy muy
sencillo de acordarse así que estos
aviones van a migrar en esta dirección y
los cationes los cationes que en este
caso serán los iones de sodio positivo
van a migrar hacia el cátodo así que
esta es una forma fácil de acordarnos
los aviones migran hacia el ánodo y los
cationes migran hacia el acá
muy bien ahora finalmente vamos a pensar
cómo hacer la notación abreviada y esto
es un poquito molesto digamos de dibujar
cada vez que tengamos que explicar cómo
es nuestra celda voltaicas y que hay una
notación abreviada que podemos utilizar
para no estar dibujando esto una y otra
vez así que vamos a empezar escribiendo
la anotación abreviada primero colocamos
nuestro ánodo verdad en este caso el
ánodo es el zinc en este caso el ánodo
es el zinc así que tenemos sin sólido
vamos a escribirlo aquí tenemos
sólido y luego colocamos una línea
vertical simple una línea vertical
simple que representa digamos una
frontera entre el zinc sólido y nuestra
solución acuosa de iones de 5-2 positivo
así que vamos a escribir estos iones de
zinc 2 positivo de este lado es decir ya
hemos representado a nuestro electrodo
de zinc verdad y los iones de 5-2
positivo ahora colocamos una doble línea
vertical y esto representa nuestro
puente de sal verdad la línea vertical
doble representa el puente de sal y
luego colocamos el cobre dos positivos
colocamos el cobre 2 positivo verdad
déjenme circular esto en verde estamos
colocando el cobre 2 positivo del lado
izquierdo habíamos colocado los iones de
5-2 positivo y el electrodo ahora hemos
puesto los iones de cobre 2 positivo y
ahora dibujamos una línea vertical que
nuevamente representa
transfrontera verdad nuevamente
representa nuestra frontera y colocamos
el cobre sólido verdad estamos colocando
nuestro electrodo o bien nuestro cut o
ahora lo que hay simplemente que
recordar es que el ánodo siempre se
encuentra del extremo izquierdo mientras
que el cátodo se encuentra siempre en el
extremo derecho verdad y esto es muy
fácil de recordar porque digamos la
letra a va antes que la ce cierto
entonces el ánodo se pone del lado
izquierdo porque la va antes que la ce y
el cátodo se pone hasta el otro extremo
porque la c va después de la muy bien
entonces tenemos una forma digamos
resumida de representar una celda en vez
de estar dibujando esta imagen
gigantesca cada vez que necesitemos
hablar de ello verdad simplemente lo
podemos ver escrito de esta forma y es
como viene en algunos libros de texto de
química así que esencialmente esta
expresión de aquí nos está diciendo la
misma información que tenemos en esta
figura